[Music]
[Applause]
we're sorry serene hat but you've got
your work cut out for you
The Dance Moms crew isn't made up of
super simple people quite on the
contrary really these stars possess many
different traits which can make them
challenging to read but then again
you're the sorting hat for crying out
loud so you totally know what you're up
against and hey if you could sort Harry
Potter then you can definitely sort
Maddie Ziegler The Dance Moms cast is
made up of many different personalities
which is sure to keep things interesting
we're about to sort out our favorite
dancers into their respective Hogwarts
houses so don't go anywhere you won't
believe which house Maddie Ziegler is
destined to thrive in Mackenzie Ziegler
she's sassy brave and doesn't pay
attention to the rules which is why
Mackenzie Ziegler is a true born
Gryffindor she acts now and asks
questions later it has a knack for
getting into trouble Kenzie is brave at
heart and very outgoing
the youngest Ziglar sister has nerve
determination and courage
Chloe Lucchese ak hello as the KZ AK is
one of the brightest stars on Dance Moms
she's sharp accepting and super original
we're not too surprised to find out that
Chloe belongs in Ravenclaw after all she
did get accepted into Pepperdine
University which is no small feat Chloe
would make Rowena Ravenclaw proud Camryn
bridges cameron bridges isn't a mean
girl but she's not about to let others
step all over her either she is
hardworking dedicated and super modest
making her a great addition to the
hufflepuffs house contrary to popular
belief
hufflepuffs are timid pushovers who
never come out on top sure they're
friendly and fair but there is my tea as
the feisty honey badger when pushed
Kendall vertes can lavertus is one of
those people who are sort of hard to
store it into a one category at first
glance she comes off as a total
Slytherin after all she's played the
mean grow a few times
but according to Kindle her true
personality wasn't allowed to shine on
Dance Moms
Kindle prides herself on being a good
friend who is loyal and hard-working
she's a Hufflepuff through and through
Nia soon Nia sue is by far the nicest
person to have ever danced on the set of
Dance Moms
she's a great friend who always offers
her support and she's super dedicated to
the virtues she pursues but unlike
Kendall Nia doesn't belong in hufflepuff
she belongs in her ravenclaw Nia is the
underrated smart girl of the groom she's
wise creative and sharpest attack
Liliana catchman really quickly became
the new Maddie on Dance Moms
season eight she's clever and vicious
and cunning making her the perfect
Slytherin Lily knows how important
leadership is for success which is why
she's all for it
Lilly is living proof that slytherins
are far from evil
Jojo see Wow dudas she was super nice
and always willing to go the extra mile
for her fans it's easy to see that Jojo
belongs in Hufflepuff I like it she's
hard-working kind and super dedicated to
honing her craft it's no wonder that
Jojo excels in everything she does she
definitely knows how to work a crowd
while being totally genuine Kalani
Hilliker Kalani Hilliker has a strong
sense of leadership and
self-preservation she knows how to talk
her way out of a hectic situation
despite being the one who started the
fire in the first place clearly Kalani
belongs in the Hogwarts dungeons with
the rest of the slytherins
her ambition speaks for itself Paige
Highland Paige Highland didn't have an
easy run on Dance Moms
despite being hardworking and determined
Paige couldn't impress her teacher and
eventually lost all passion for dance
Paige is a lover not a fighter
making her the perfect addition to the
Hufflepuff house Brady Farrar Brady
Ferrara is determined to read the best
he's got a lot of nerve and is known for
his chivalry being the only boy in Abby
Lee Miller's dance squad isn't for the
faint-hearted he's brave and daring and
100% determined so we're not too
surprised that Brady is a Gryffindor at
heart Brooke Hyland unlike her sister
Paige Brooke Hyland is destined to spend
most of her time studying in the
ravenclaw common room Brooke doesn't
take her studies lightly she's got a
degree in marketing
and management as well as a business
degree she's smart authentic and
creative which is why she is destined to
sleep in the Ravenclaw tower Bren
raballo
Brynn might be shy and reserved at times
but a-line is waiting to roar inside of
her
obviously Brynn was destined to join the
Gryffindor House she's mentally strong
and focused and always makes her own
decisions she follows her heart and he's
brave to a fault Ileana Walmsley she's
witty wise and super original but
Allegan is so much more than that she's
quick on her feet and intellectual to
boots making her the perfect ravenclaw
Eliana can learn choreographies in the
blink of an eye filius Flitwick would be
proud Abby Lee Miller when it comes to
dance teacher Abby Lee Miller it's easy
to see that she belongs in Slytherin
Abby is a mean girl he'll do anything to
get her way no one is as determined as
her and she has a strong sense of
fraternity Maddie Ziegler just like her
former dance teacher Maddie Ziegler
belongs in Slytherin Maddie will do
anything to win a competition and she's
determined to get the highest score
Horace Slughorn would definitely try to
recruit her into his club of exceptional
students which Hogwarts house do you
belong in and why sound off in the
comments and that's a wrap subscribe to
the things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]